[Music]  demi lovato gets real about her ongoing  battle with an eating disorder I lay it  all out on the line and I'm very very  honest the sorry not sorry singer shared  a shocking before an after photo of  herself on Instagram Tuesday and  captioned the side-by-side mirror  selfies quote recovery is possible I'm  on a journey to discover what it's like  to be free of all demons  Dimmie has been open about her struggles  with bulimia over the years even  admitting in her new youtube  documentaries simply complicated that  she has relapsed before to cope with  loneliness but one thing that I haven't  fully conquered is my eating disorder  I relapse  Benji  when government she told et her  vulnerable approach is her way of not  only helping herself but helping others  suffering  I want to prevent my fans from going  through the things that I went through  so that kind of honesty is what I have  throughout the documentary  [Music]